buenos días la presenta la comisión
europea se ha centrado sobre todo en
hablar de esta europa del futuro que
emerge a partir de ahora de esta europa
pandemia con anuncios que han sido
generalmente muy bien recibidos dentro
de la eurocámara para empezar ha hablado
de la importancia de la juventud de los
jóvenes de estos jóvenes que han sufrido
también la pandemia muchos han tenido
que quedarse encerrados en sus casas sin
apenas contacto social por ello ha
avanzado que es momento que también
europa esté centrada en ellos y por ello
el 2022 el año 2022 será el año europeo
de los jóvenes con la creación de un
programa por ejemplo de jóvenes
trabajadores para que los jóvenes puedan
irse a trabajar a otro estado miembro y
mantener así su joven formación al
laboral también ha hablado de la
importancia que debe darse también
europa en cuestiones como la tecnología
y por ello ha avanzado la creación de
una ley de chips especialmente para
depender menos de chin en cuestiones
como los semiconductores muy importantes
por ejemplo la creación de los los
eléctricos los ordenadores o también los
móviles celular celulares también en
esta parte de dar más importancia a
europa ha hablado de la defensa la
creación de la unión europea de defensa
para que tengan sus propios soldados una
cuestión que lleva años hablando se
dentro de la unión europea pero para que
esté así presidente en regiones donde la
onu o tampoco la otan estén presentes
por ejemplo la región del sahel que
aunque no la ha mencionado es de
importancia estratégica para francia al
respecto de hecho ha criticado la falta
de voluntad política de algunos países
europeos también quiere hablar de
recuperar el papel frente al auge de
china en cuestiones como por ejemplo en
las infraestructuras de las inversiones
en regiones como la indo-pacífica o
también la el continente africano y por
ello han hablado de la creación de un
portal global de infraestructuras para
hacer frente también a la conocida como
la ruta de la seda china y ya para
acabar también ha avanzado la creación
de una ley contra la violencia machista
para seguir las mujeres brevemente este
es el balance sobre la pandemia
si así es ha hablado de este de la
campaña de vacunación en que está
superado el 70 por ciento de europeos ya
vacunados ha habido poco margen a la
autocrítica ha obviado los problemas que
hubo a principios de año sobre la
campaña de vacunación pero aún así ha
dicho que la unión europea ha ayudado
también a otros países como por ejemplo
avanzado la donación de 200 millones de
dosis más para los países menos
favorecidos ursula von der leyen ha
sacado pecho y ha asegurado que mientras
el resto del mundo hablaba la unión
europea ha actuado